for some it's about brand loyalty for
some it's about aspirations that are
marketed and advertised different ways
but but let me try to answer it as a
kind of technical question question of a little bit
more as a technical question
so some of this comes down to
the ways in which we think about
computer systems
so generally if you think about it
this way you have what we would call the
hardware then on top of this we have a
special set of programs called the
operating system and on top of the
operating system you will have what's
called applications, yeah? now all of those also have what, broadly
speaking, is a windowing system
so this is the ways in which they present
themselves to you
this would be you, you would interact
with a window, say, and that window
would interact with what processing
applications say that what process an
application would ask that the
underlying operating system to do
certain things like opening a file and that
opening a file would make certain things
happen on the hardware. so there's quite a
long history of different operating
systems, from the very first inception
you would have different operating
systems which would run in different
manufacturers equipment so IBM would
have one Honeyware would have another ICL
would have another and all of those
different systems would each have their own
operating systems
so the BBC micro had one, the Commodore
64 had another and all of those would
come and go so they'd be closely kind of
tied to the hardware. historically
what's happened is that they'd also, each of
those manufacturers, would offer a
different way of presenting the computer
so they have different windowing
systems
so originally did they would simply be
commanding, you type out a command line
and something would happen
but macs and pcs have been two of the
main competitors, at one point
through the early eighties the big
diference that people would speak about
would be the windowing system difference.
one was graphical one had a desktop made
for it, the other didn't. with the advent of
that sort of facility on Windows
machines that difference is less clear
so a windows 8 machine and a Macintosh
interface uses icons many recognise in
in similar ways
but you still will have a religious
separation between people about both
each to each say but only in slightly
different ways
so today I think the real difference
between them is that Apple still own and
build the hardware that they put their
operating system on so they exist both
is a software company and a hardware
company and it's only recently that
Microsoft have even attempted to do that
again
so the microsoft surface is the first
time Microsoft have thought to do this
why is that important? Well, it's
important because what the operating
system has to do is translate the
applications needs into things for
the computer, the hardware, to do and if
you've built that hardware
you know how the hardware works, you can
optimize in particular ways. if you don't
then you can't necessarily do that
quite as smoothly and quite as
efficiently. So detecting things
happening in the hardware is more
difficult if you haven't built it because
you're relying on other people building
things. so that's why
the operating systems in Macintoshes can actually make
presumptions about the hardware and
it's use and therefore build an optimized
and can test it
so they've actually tested their systems
with the actual hardware that they
run on Microsoft have a different
orientation their operating systems
are installed in many manufacturers' hardware
and so they can't really test it on every single
possible machine, so that means that not
as optimal at that point or smooth at
that point and they're relying on what's
called device drivers being specifically
installed for each device so that would
translate the operating system commands
specifics of that hardware. that's why
often you see when you're using a pc
machine or Microsoft machine you will
see our own need to reinstall and update
and change different drivers, mostly
those are invisible in the Macintosh
because they're pretty much owned by
apple and installed by Apple and updated
by Apple. the plus side of this is that
it feels nice and and more efficient
the downside of this is you've only got
one machine that it runs on and therefore
you've got a concealed unit which means
that Macintosh machines are often accused
of being more expensive
because on windows, on windows type
devices,
you can run it on a range of hardware
from high to low end and you can
optimize the place of the hardware down
by running on that
where as you don't have that range of
hardware in quite the same way. i've used
Macintosh's and Microsoft as the kind of
classic divisions that people use, but if
you actually go through the the range of
others this separation down into
different systems also applies
so in terms of Linux, Linux roots are
from original open source unix
people of taking the converging unix
platform and ported and made it work
on a pc environment and set
pc environments and so that operating
system is capable of running across a
wide range of hardware. and also there is
a number of windowing systems that it
itself supports now the advantage with
Linux environments is that Linux environments
are open
so no corporation or company owns them
quite the same way
they're open source and modifiable by
people, and people can moderate
them and use them so its championed as one
of the classic, it's championed
one of the biggest forces for
keeping the internet and computer
systems open and accessible to all
floating-point looks at one tenth plus two tenth,
what you just typed in, 0.1 plus 0.2
in decimal, and it says that one tenth plus two tenth
does not quite
equal three tenths because, to its mind, it doesn't.